neo is in the house to talk his new you
to Brett series and his baby boy on the
way plus the Kim Kardashian imposters
that got us doing a double tape and Tom
Hardy finally makes good on his Oscars
bet with Leonardo DiCaprio
hello my friends in case you forgot this
is the daily Denny and I told you I had
some fun interviews lined up for you
this week and I was not lying because
the multi-talented neo stop by and the
dudes got so much going on right now
he just started filming world of dance
season 2 with JLo it's part of the new
YouTube red series step of high water
and he's expecting another baby boy who
covered it all during our Facebook live
chat you're adding another team member
yes let me clear something up okay so a
couple days ago wife you posted an older
picture of when when our our youngest
SJ was born and everybody was oh my god
congratulations the baby's like we only
found one thing new was not here you're
not yet but please send the gifts
nothing will take the goods yes I mean
doesn't get any less you're obviously a
father to three kids already doesn't get
any less stressful preparing for a new
baby no no no yeah we see the times like
the first time so you have a daughter
and two sons and I know you said you
wanted a girl getting aboard yeah what
were you hoping for a girl I kind of
wanted to even it out you know as of
right now um you know my my two oldest
with Maddy and Mason Maddy seven Mason
is six Mason at the very least has my
sister's son you know they they they
partner up and play out of time Maddy's
kind of by herself you know me so I
wanted to give her wanted to give her a
little sister to have you know just some
camaraderie but it she was actually
caught she was actually really pissing
up about know she's broken up about it
not being a girl oh you wish you wanted
a sister but I broke it out to it like
listen no now you have three little
henchmen they gotta do whatever you tell
them to then you have three look three
low dues to boss around all day long go
for it so you're here talking about
step-up high water yes your new series
on YouTube red how does it compare to
like the movies that were used right
well everybody knows that the step-up
films and
they're known for the amazing dance
sequences as a whole nine so I feel like
we've gone just we've we've elevated to
that next level with the series this is
this one is very much more story and
character based you know the dancing is
definitely there you know it's this step
but we couldn't not do the dancing
there's some drama in there there's some
suspense this is it's not I'll say this
it's not what you've come to know from
the films okay it's it's a lid it's a
little grittier look where I'm in there
you know what it actually reminds me of
the very first one that first step up
with Chani and Jenna you know oh yeah
sure
can we expect her or Channing or to pop
up in the series at all um well I don't
want to give anything okay all right so
we'll just have to tune in to name we'll
have to watch it and doing any watch ten
episodes to find out y'all you guys can
watch the first four episodes of step up
hi waterful free those are up now on
YouTube bread alright next Kim
kardashian-west has an imposter okay
actually it's Kim's rumored frenemy
Paris Hilton making us do a total double
take
Paris is among those featured in Kanye's
Yeezy season six campaign and the
concept recreating Kim's paparazzi shots
in her easy threads Kim giving nod to
her old pal Paris captioning this shot
the og a far cry from the days when
Paris was the one with a hit reality
show and hired a 23 year old Kim to
organize her closets man I missed the
early 2000s our Paris is one of the
friends and Instagram models Kim they
recruited for the campaign including
Kylie's BFF Jordan Woods an army of Kim
clones operating on social media versus
Vogue magazine very untraditional which
means it's very Kanye and the Internet
is freaking out over it so the joke is
on us because he's got our attention
what do you guys think enlisting a
diverse group of women to model the
clothes and post on their instagrams
genius move or what let us know in the
comment section now ok we're switching
gears though to Tom Hardy who has made
his love for Leonardo DiCaprio permanent
check it out Tom got Leo knows all inked
on his arm
pics posted a party with a fan in San
Francisco where he just wrapped filming
venom shows a new
on his right bicep now this is all
because Tommy boy lost a bet to Leo
this revenant co-star bet two years ago
that Tom would get an Oscar nomination
for his role in the movie a prediction
Tom humbly and wrongly bet against since
Leo was right Hardy how to get those
words tattooed to his body and now Tom
will never forget it proof two always
believe in yourself kids though hey if
Leo you want to write a little message
I'll gladly tat it up alright guys
thanks for watching as always give this
video a thumbs up if you liked it and
I'll be back tomorrow with some more
peace
[Music]